Iran has not changed much other than the
names are different in terms of who the
Supreme Leader is we need a president
who's going to back away from that deal
in Iran and set the record straight if
these folks want to bring back a seventh
century version of Islam then my
recommendation is let's load our bombers
up and bomb them back to the seventh
century what should our strategy be on
global jihadist and terrorists I refer
them to the movie taken have you seen
the movie taken Liam Neeson he has a
line and this is what our strategy
should be we will look for you we will
find you and we will kill you I've
created tens of thousands of jobs over
my career tens of thousands and I would
be the greatest job president ever in my
opinion every coin in our pocket every
bill in our wallet says and God We Trust
if it's in our founding documents it's
in our pledge it's in our courts it's on
our money but we're not supposed to talk
about it what in the world is that and
medicine we call it schizophrenia
several weeks ago I was asked by a
reporter whether a woman's hormones
prevented her from serving in the Oval
Office
now ladies this is a test can any of you
think of a single example in which a
man's judgment was clouded by his
hormones any at all even in the Oval
Office let's let America be America
again god bless you thank you brother